hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we have more of the
series that is black clover as we embark
on a review of the fifth arc in the
series known as the
underwater temple the very mention of
which gave me some pretty
extreme ptsd vibes in regards to every
water temple and the legend of zelda
ever however this black clover related
experience was far more enjoyable which
speaking of if you dear viewer are
finding these videos enjoyable then
kindly do the thing it is where you
subscribe to this your youtube channel
as well as like the video to let me know
that you want more black clovery stuff
as per usual i'm unlikely to be reading
the comments in this video for spoiler
reasons so that's how you let me know
but as for the underwater temple like
most black clover related stories thus
far we have quite a simple setup evil
people
are after magic stone magic stone is in
temple protagonists go to temple to get
magic stone easy done except this time
things are simplified once more because
this is essentially a black bull
exclusive story in previous arcs we've
been taking quite a bit of time to
feature other factions of the magic
knights or the diamond kingdom
but on this occasion it's pretty much
all about the bulls which i appreciated
we've been spending quite a while now
learning about them one by one so it was
very satisfying to see them all come
together as a group and just watch how
they interact with one another which was
quite shenanigan refilled
i mean i say all of them but there is
still this one apparently dude that we
have yet to meet the sort of goth
looking guy who was hardcounted by the
very concept of a beach
that's fine though it's always nice to
keep some mystery in play of course it's
not quite as simple as recovering a
miscellaneous rock though because the
temple is a pain to get into and even
when they do the squad are lured into a
game after which their game gets crashed
by the most powerful threat we face to
this point with mr midnight
cult guy so there's lots and lots to go
through but i'm going to start with noel
this arc gave her some much needed focus
because
as of late she's been a bit on the
sidelines and in fact she spent the
entirety of the last arc as comic-con
relief being all obsessed with astor and
stuff
and there's a tiny bit of that here but
it quickly shifts to surpassing her
limits a phrase which is repeated many
many many many many times during the
sock one that we've heard before but is
really cemented here but it's really
nice to see noel grow and she proved
invaluable during the course of the
underwater temple which is of course an
ideal venue for her water magic but in
addition to having a breakthrough
allowing her to take the bulls into the
temple noel is actually the first
character to get in a decent hit on our
main antagonist as well she actually has
startlingly phenomenal power which
continues to make her a nice contrast to
asta the ultimate talent in magic
standing alongside the ultimate talent
of
not magic and we also got to know a bit
more about noel as well
specifically why she was ostracized by
her family it's not just a lack of magic
control but apparently giving birth
noelle also killed the matriarch of the
family so all of her siblings despise
noel for that especially because she
can't even replace that loss by being a
classically
noble mage thing doesn't matter those
guys suck they still suck
so hard and noel has the black balls now
all of whom come to cheer her on early
on in the arc and noel repays those
bonds by standing proud at the
action-packed climax almost importantly
she has her own fuego leon moment
remembering his words about being weak
which is one of my favorite quotes i
think
ever and i really do love this because
in the last arc astor had a very similar
moment
remembering fuego leon's words to him so
these two are both growing
and it's fantastic but to talk about the
setting for a bit after noel actually
gets everyone in there the underwater
temple is indeed pretty cool but it felt
a bit underexplored to me i really like
that there was this whole civilization
down there i think that was much better
than just entering another empty temple
like the first dungeon we did but in the
end i just feel like i know
next to nothing about these guys you
know who are they why do they live down
here why can't they just go up to the
surface
they clearly have magic powerful enough
to do so so
what gives and these questions may be
answered in the future but despite the
fact that it really wasn't explored that
well in my opinion i guess
it plays into one of the overall themes
of the series being discrimination in
general either they are discriminated
against by those living on the surface
or the undersea dwellers prefer to stay
isolated for
sea dwelling reasons i don't know why
and i really do wish we'd gotten to know
a bit more about their culture because
they feel quite glossed over even our
more mainsea characters being kyoto and
kohono they had their own dreams and
tragedy but something about them just
didn't really seem to equate to the
other arc specific side characters that
we'd met up until this point the two of
them were just a bit more shallow which
is ironic given how far underwater we
were you know what doesn't really matter
though because as stated before this arc
is all about the black balls and i do
want to mention briefly just how well
thought out this scenario is from
tarpita i've mentioned this before but
he's pretty phenomenal at creating these
very natural situations like in any
other series giving such an important
mission to a band of absolute misfits
and keeping our rookie protagonists at
the forefront can be a very difficult
task
because logically there are just better
people for the job but
solves problems like these with such an
envious ease the black balls need to be
used because of the fear of a traitor
and other squads the army can't be
involved in the action because the game
would be deemed uninteresting with him
there and asta needs to be the one to
play a key role in slicing up the bad
guy because even when they know it
exists
anti-magic is still such an overpowered
x-factor in combat and so it all just
kind of works with seemingly no effort
at all meanwhile all of the effort is
seen portrayed amongst the black bulls
themselves this was such a great
showcase of teamwork with all of them
splitting off into smaller groups and
one duo that really took my eye was mana
and luck with the whole mini flashback
about the first time that mana had met
luck and how he became his first friend
and everything it was quite touching
seeing these goofballs together and even
better was that it was another emotional
realization not
triggered by astor so it felt more
natural and earned in fact that in
general was the really big selling point
to me about this arc we finally got to
see the black balls just
interact with each other absent avasta
and i love their dynamic it's such a
fascinating group to follow and another
fun combination during the arc would be
goshen grey
gray being someone who i honestly did
not remember meeting
likely because she was someone else at
the time but gray happens to have one of
my favorite magic types at the moment
though because transformation magic is
kind of like the ultimate introvert
skill set i
am truly truly envious of her ability to
just walk around as anyone she sees fit
and also it was one of those stupidly
clever combinations from tabitha with
gauche being a mirror user and gray
essentially being a reflection so i do
appreciate little thematic details like
that with that said my favorite team up
by far was the final trio of asta
vanessa and finra mostly because i never
would have predicted those two to be
such
perfect partners for astr i mean vanessa
said it best herself when she asked
how can you trust a drunk woman in a
superficial wimp with your life
and you know it's kind of true like they
were really the last two i expected to
be caught up in the ultimate battle of
the ark but they both also had their own
little flashbacks and moments and it was
just so damn good to watch these three
completely ruin veto someone who none of
these three have any business standing
up to whatsoever his power is ridiculous
and it was like watching skilled players
take down a raid boss in a game
and speaking of let's let's get to veto
i feel like i
should care about him but i don't not
yet anyway and i think that's
intentional
because after he was beaten and killed
tumba to stages this moment of respect
for vetto from yami and astor the latter
of which states that the one who felt
the most despair was obviously better so
there's this undoubtedly very sad story
behind this man that i just don't know
yet and look i say
man but that's probably wrong with all
of this mythical beast magic at play
that one was a bit of a surprise
actually and noel even recalled a story
she was told as a young member of
nobility about a race of demons and look
something tells me that whatever veto
actually was they probably weren't all
that evil that just strikes me as the
general
direction of black clover victims turn
perpetrators and all that so whilst i
still honestly don't care about veto
right now i can see a situation where we
learn of his past and the past of his
race and i look back on this and go oh
that's actually
really sad although i have to say his
obsession with despair was
well look the word despair is it's kind
of ruined for me it's honestly hard for
me to take seriously because i am a huge
huge fan of the danganronpa games where
simply saying the word despair is like
breathing oxygen so that's all i could
think of each and every time veto did so
but i did love the moment where he got
smacked in the face with the realization
right at the end that not a single
character had expressed even a shred of
despair against him in this whole
scenario
not one so suck it bad guy
who probably isn't all that bad after
all and i suppose we should move on to
asta for a bit now he's kind of always
an afterthought for me but there was one
super important moment during this arc
where we got to see that devil shadow
thing again
as well as the titular black clover
didn't get any answers regarding either
of them but
we did see them which i think is the
first time since astor received his
grimoire a boy who devours
everything even despair i'm still really
keen to know where his apparent path of
darkness takes astor because as of right
now it doesn't look like
it's had any impact on him whatsoever he
is still the epitome of optimistic and
all that is good in this world
in fact he has such a solid moral
foundation that it's almost boring and
that's what kind of weirds me out about
asta he doesn't seem to have a massive
flaw which this arc highlights actually
given that veto chastises astor for
being a hot-headed dumbass who never
gives up but then aston just turns that
on its face and basically says
na ah me being a hot-headed dumbass who
never gives up is my strongest feature
and it's just really bizarre that
despite the fact that astor is a
magicless
outcast he is still kind of perfect he
picks up non-magic related skills almost
instantly everyone loves him they're all
inspired by him most of the women want
to be with him and even his main rival
yuno treats him with the utmost respect
he's such a weird stereotypical yet
not stereotypical shonen protagonist
meanwhile yami is indeed the best as per
usual and like i said before the reason
to keep him out of most of this arc was
simple but effective high priest man
knew the game would be boring with him
involved and that's that
and i like that because characters like
yami can be very problematic yami is at
the point where he's so powerful that it
really makes no sense not to have him
involved in every serious situation so i
do hope that tabitha is good enough to
keep making these strategically
dramatically favorable decisions and
yami of course also has the best line of
the arc where he's speaking to his squad
and he just says
all of you surpassed your limits right
here and now if you die
i'll kill you that is all and hey
wouldn't you know that's what everyone
did and amongst all of that yami himself
finds a way to surpass his own limits
and we get to see him level up which was
very cool
although he does also hog all of the
glory taking down veto single-handedly
after the amazing effort put in by the
rest of the squad but you know i'm okay
with that because it's yami oh and
something else involving yami tambita
seems to have gone to some great lengths
in this arc to make it very clear that
the magic knight ranking system is not
to be equated with power which yes we
did already know however it gets spelled
out to us pretty clearly with all the
other black balls being junior magic
knights apparently who then go on to
fight very well against the equivalent
of intermediate and
even senior ranks and that also gets
taken a step further when those juniors
also combine to take on the main
antagonist who is either on or above the
level of a captain
so ranking wanking whatever doesn't
matter all i know is that i want more
charmy she was absolutely
robbed in this arc and needs more action
immediately but other than that another
very nice arc from black clover i should
also add that the black balls got
thanked at the end which was a new
experience for them as they are
generally looked down upon outcast so
that was all
nice and new but that pretty much does
it for this blind review of the
underwater temple arc of black clover
and what do you guys think please do
leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for more black clover
content then please do go and check out
some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for
very maybe regular black clover goodness
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review
and i'll see you next time